Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today I will show you some papers
and results with Stable Diffusion,
a free and open source image generator AI. And
I cannot believe how good these results are.
First, we had an earlier example with ControlNet
and dancing. This means that in goes something,
for instance, a video of us, and out
comes a hand drawn anime version of
it. Now, the advantage of this is
that we don’t need to look perfect,
and we don’t even need to be at this exact
place in the background, because all of this
can be synthesized. And today, someone took
this idea to the next level. Look. And now,
if you think this is a blue haired woman converted
into to a more painterly blue haired woman… well,
have a look at this. Oh yes, we don’t even need
to be the character we want to be, we just need
to kind of look like the character we want to
be. This is going to be an amazing tool for the
digital artists of the future. And remember,
this needs a tiny bit of time and expertise,
but it is something that you can run for
free on your own machine, and some of the
other examples, even in your pocket, on
your smartphone. What a time to be alive!
Two, we can even use Stable Diffusion’s
ControlNet to provide it input images for
it to redraw. For instance, we can give it this
childhood drawing, and we can ask this little AI
to create a super high quality version of
it. My goodness. This is incredibly good.
Three, now here is a crazy idea. Why not give
it a QR-code as an input image, and see what
happens? Well, these look great…so this was
a good thought experiment, but of course,
these won’t work as QR codes. Just as a piece
of art. Wait a second. Hold on to your papers,
Fellow Scholars, do they actually work as QR-codes
and are they readable from a smartphone camera?
Yes they are! Make sure to play with the distance
a bit, perhaps increase the distance a little,
but every single one of these work for me. I
can’t believe it. Artificial creativity. Wow.
Four, and these video to video workflows
are becoming so incredibly good that…are
you seeing what I am seeing? Can that
really be? These can now be generated
almost immediately. If we wish to create a
smoother video, we would have to wait a bit,
but not in the order of hours. Just in the
order of seconds, and super quick previews
can be done like this. This would not have been
possible just a few months ago. Unbelievable.
Five, with the right prompts, Stable
Diffusion can also create an 1800s
version of our favorite rockstars. Elton John,
Freddie Mercury, Dave Grohl, Hendrix or Jagger,
you name it. I love how creative some of
these solutions are and how they retain
their looks and personalities while
putting them into an 1800s setting.
Six, we can also create custom portraits for our
dungeons and dragons characters.
Just give the AI the description,
and there we go. The prompts and the workflow
for some of these images are available,
which means that you can likely reproduce
and tweak them yourself at home. So good.
Seven, in the meantime, Google just published
a really cool paper on how to guide these image
generator AIs with natural language. First,
we can ask for an image of a giant macaron
and croissant in front of the Eiffel Tower. Well,
yes, I hear you saying, Doc, with today’s papers,
that is not surprising. What is surprising
is that without generating a new image,
we can swap these objects, enlarge
the macaron, and if we don’t like it,
replace it with a different one, or even better
use our own photo and ask it to recapture its
appearance. Which it had done really well as
the lighting now also has an effect on these
objects as well. Not just the background
is different, everything is different. So,
interacting with text to image AIs via
natural language. How cool is that?
Eight, creating zoom videos has also improved
a great deal. Now we can choose a few images,
and stitch them together to
create these zoom videos,
and they are now really smooth. Previous
ones had some flickering issues,
but this one is now so much better. And all this
improvement in just a few months! Unbelievable.
I put a link to all of these
works in the video description,
and for now, let the experiments begin!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!